[Musica]
benvenuto questo nuovo video sono pari j
come sempre che la rete stati subito di
rocket league stavolta ragazzi volevo
provare a fare una partita da solo per
vedere insomma gravissimo registrino che
clip da solo e questa cosa importante
almeno che non parli di storielle lo
vedremo oggi non parlo di nulla voglio
giocare e basta
facciamo questo esperimento allora sono
arrivato diamante 2 un sacco di gente
che crede che basti saper volare non
capisce perché io si erano 32 pro poi
perdono perché il gioco non c'è solo
quello ci sono tante cose sono arrivate
davanti a due comunque dopo c'è il
champion quindi quell'ora anche
veramente altissimo
mi mancano due run chini per arrivare lì
però la vedo veramente difficile se non
ci arriverò mai però proviamo citate
ragazzi sto usando la fennec che questa
macchina qua che mi avete consigliato
voi in un live
non so più usandola vulcan anche quella
che usavo in tutti i libri praticamente
per vedere come riesco a trovarmi con la
fenech è molto difficile da manovrare
all'inizio perché non lo sai anche
perché per gira stessa più difficili
difficoltà quella roba lì capito già
vice bocchino ripartire to complimenti o
un compagno stupido molti non è partito
anzi ha attivato la retromarcia perché
invece andare avanti alla tal indietro
ottimo abbiamo perso solofra
il compagno stupido gioco sempre molto
contento finora della partenza tanto
ragazzi fa ste striscie di turbo
facciamo che iniziamo subito dalla
prossima partita che mi sta che questo
qua non è proprio svegli perfetto
ragazzi siamo in una nuova partita
speriamo stavolta pseudo decente il mio
compagno
sono partito io ma non fa niente vai vai
paesi
vai sì o no turbo uno turbo ma ci credo
non lo turba ma ci credono stato uno
solo turbo ci ho provato mai domi fai
dai conto ma li vai tommy prendere
quanto vali vai tommi tommi qua il
signor fa vi fa il signor favi che non
controlla milano turbo effettivamente
usato tutto per arrivati in qua però il
signor tommy può tentare di buttarla in
mezzo i sino torni ragazzi io non posso
fare un compagno che sia decenni non lo
posso avere io non c'è un compagno che
sappia giocare a questo gioco di me ai
ragazzi allora 2 a 0 si può rifare
ancora tutto 6 comincia a giocare il
primo attenzione e dopo di buttarla in
mezzo per lui la rata continuare
però tirato per niente lui la parte
bellissimo sacro scuola bellissimo vai
prato oddio che hanno scavalcato
fortissimo ok non sia mercato va bene la
palla
bellissimo misura proprio lui cosa tommy
fa vedere chi sei prendi un po di
punteggio anche tu so che posso credere
in te basta dire che i compagni fanno
schifo
iniziamo a credere nei propri compagni
bravo bravo scherzavo scherzavamo
promotori sarà il turbo io sono molto
più veloce che potevo più di così non
potevo fare
sono arrivato a missile pronte non
potevo fare che non avevo il turbo frate
o para la quale sono qui niente proprio
non sa fare un cazzo
peccato perché era promettente sfiga
spiega ancora una ragazza non sia il
faringei francia no beh ragazzi se mi ha
preso per il culo messi e j
ma come com'è possibile tutto questo va
il compagno dal nome impronunciabile che
neanche si muove in partenza va bene
dobbiamo abbattere messi e j fratello c6
giochiamo a d'oro che trig bene fa
reparto io non ripartono
no non ricordo di paesi come qualcosa
bravo bravo bravo bravo buona lo zio po
la bravissima un tronco poi decente
butta li metto potrei mai tenute in
mezzo punto e mezzo ha avuto io ho avuto
una brutta gesù attenzione non soltanto
adesso avevano più belle importa
no ho sbagliato io il controllo
sbagliato io quest'ora gol era gol da
fare peccato che gli aveva fatto una
cazzata allucinante sorry ho fatto
veramente una cagata frate devi andare
in porta se non segnano che bravo larga
o fate una cagata quello doveva essere
gol al cento per cento lo dico io
bravissimo e 3a po apea papa sia jv
dispiace che non ride messi e jazz che
effettivamente mi voleva rubare il
lavoro promessi e j
chi sa veramente in francia madonna come
lo presta come l'ho presa come l'ha
presa pazzesco
mammamia lo pignolo
lo bloccata sulle spalle stato
stranissimo confavi proprio lui mezzi e
j
e mi dispiace perché avevo un odio
repentino su chi gioca rocket ligue
francese cioè non si può perché valore
però la francia si batte si batte la
francia non si può perdere
dalla francia perché portiamo in alto il
valore dei mondiali fabio grosso 6 frate
oddio no siamo scarsi tu sei scemo cosa
c'è di quello di una fila di vetro tira
in rete ragazzi spaziamo la spaziamo la
zio facciamola come giochiamo qua
che sofferenza continua spaziamo st
palla via via una botta e via
ma è una botta e via ok perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto dal suo
perfetto questo controllo buono
no vennero scartato come un pezzo di
carta che si di cioccolatino che si
scalda ma va bene lo stesso ben due gol
bonfà vi porta avanti ancora meno anno
hanno sondato quindi teoricamente
abbiamo vinto
speriamo almeno uno ricorso nel dato non
si agevole tenere in alto il nome della
j
ma non si è accorto c'è il sottoscritto
valore mi piace frase è stato bravo
signor ea poe a me come ti chiami dei
ragazzi questa quest'anno le due partite
di oggi di rocket league spero vi siano
piaciute perché da un po duro portarlo
per i giudici anche per i carc i miei
purtroppo essendo timo folgaria team non
puoi quali giochi con il tuo team quindi
se tu compagno fa schifo alle volte
faccio schifo anch'io non è però vero
che il mio compagno non faccia sempre
schifo se no devo carlo è un casino
ragazzi speriamo in questo caso mi è
andata anche normalmente bene perché
cover comiche di lo vedevo che era una
promessa
prometto mi sono mettermi in futuro farà
faville però a parte le battute di me
spero che gli sia piaciuto questa
decisione venuto mi piace e iscritti al
canale
sono in campo con la possiamo prendere
che il bel ragazzo
[Musica]